i was a lifeguard so i know how to use
whistle by the way just you know
so you hear that
okay take the whistle away
there you
go my name is george moats and
hamburgers are my thing but you know
that already you know what else is my
thing topping speed round let's do this
we've done a lot of toppings rounds you
remember any of them the fluff screamer
the cashew burger goober burger we did
the olive burger from michigan but just
when you thought there's no way george
can come up with more of these things
i'm not coming up with these things okay
i am just a steward to history i'm here
to give you hamburger history that's my
job and i'm telling you right now from
what i know it's up in here it's a lot
more burger information i can do this
toppings round forever
today we're going to do three original
burgers and one regional drink the
baronese burger from pj clark's in new
york city the euro burger from western
state burger in san diego the thurman
burger from thurman cafe in columbus
ohio and finally the witch doctor a
drink from whataburger in north carolina
let's do this burger number one the
berenice burger from pj clark's in new
york city pj clark's is one of the most
iconic and one of the oldest bars in new
york city it opened in 1884. the
burger's been on the menu for probably
about 100 years actually it's also a big
hangout for stars frank sinatra had his
own table there table number 20. the
baroness burger is an off menu item
see now i'm telling you secrets see this
how this works i'm telling you secrets
things you didn't know that now you do
know you can sit at table 20 frank
sinatra's table and get a baroness
burger which is off the menu whoa you
are living man you are living now the
baronese burger is pretty simple it's
nothing more than fresh ground beef that
has been grilled and put onto a toasted
bun with a big dollop of beautiful
homemade bearnaise sauce marinades is a
tarragon
and shallot infused vinegar mixed with
butter and egg yolks and it's fantastic
toasted bun we're gonna go fast
pj clark's uses
classic white squishy bun
i'm gonna use my favorite
martin's potato roll
okay i've got a three ounce ball of meat
it's probably pretty accurate to what
they would do
i want a little thicker i want to retain
those juices so it tastes like a steak
to that whoa look at that damn that's
pretty good okay
a little bit of salt on there don't get
saucy with me bernice
oh that's good
that's rich
flipping
oh look at that
like butter coming off
look at that in this case the bun is
literally just the vehicle
to get the beef and the berenais into my
face here we go
[Laughter]
oh god oh god look at that
that's it on top we go
the berenice burger
from pj clark's in new york city with a
pickle on the side okay this is very
rich
i can dip it in there like a butter
burger see that
[Laughter]
it really does taste like a steak on a
bun
on to the next burger number two
[ __ ]
burger number two
the yodel burger from western state
burger it's not there anymore don't look
for it unfortunately western steak
burger was one of my all-time favorite
spots to go for this burger
it's a burger with
gyro meat or euro meat on top of the
burger i know you're thinking well duh
of course that's going to taste good
oh it's nothing more than lamb
and beef that has been processed and
they add spices like garlic lots of
oregano now imagine that on a burger
whoa
i know what i want to do though is bring
back the legacy of western steak burger
by putting gyro meat on a burger but
instead of using traditional burger
toppings like they would have at western
state burger i'm going to use a white
sauce similar to what they put on a gyro
the white sauce i'm using though
is from another one of my favorite greek
fast food places called gyro 2 in new
york it's also closed they invented this
unbelievably sweet and tangy addictive
sauce which went on all their gyros and
everyone loved it i'm gonna put this
sauce
on this burger
that and that on a burger
the burgers at western state burger were
big for about a half a pound
it wasn't really hot
i did toasted bun also
uh toasting a bun okay toast it
yeah [ __ ] up
i'm gonna try to build this thing the
way they would have done a uto at gyro 2
in new york city which would mean the
beef would have to go on the bottom and
on top of that a hot wad of glorious
euro meat i'm going to start with some
lettuce
they would take these sort of half moons
of tomato and some raw onion then on top
of that of course the sauce a little
shake of paprika because that's what
they would have done at gyro2
keeping it all together
with the top of the bun
this is
a burger to summon
the greek gods
this is
the perfect gyro to western steak burger
i just made that up oh oh yeah
oh my god what oh my god
it's perfect it's
perfect oh my god
i'm at my happy place right now
well
we gotta go we're gonna move man burger
number three
let's do this i'm sorry that was too oh
right the garbage
oh [ __ ] me hang on a second
oh god uh jesus burger number three this
burger is the thurman burger and it
weighs in at well over a pound and a
half of ingredients the zucchasia family
opened thurman cafe over 70 years ago in
the quaint little section of columbus
known as german village and it's still
owned by the same family over 70 years
later that is got staying power man and
the burger they come for is the thurman
burger follow me here the ingredients a
three-quarter pound patty of beef
shredded lettuce tomatoes grilled onions
sauteed mushrooms pickled jalapenos
mayonnaise and
as if that weren't enough how about a
half a pound of sliced ham and to top it
all off melted american and mozzarella
cheese
on a big ass toasted bun
it's a big burger it's a very big burger
people
[Applause]
put some salt on that it's a big ass bun
for a big ass burger the ham we got a
half a pound of ham here let's get that
heated up over there
we've got some grilled onions here grill
that's also going to kind of warm those
up hang on
look at that
look at that oh this is going to get out
here too oh perfect stand back
making a mess today are we
[ __ ] sorry before we pull the patty off
we are going to dope the bun because
what they do there mayo is on the bottom
actually slice of tomato some lettuce
pickles down here also pickled jalapenos
sauteed mushrooms some grilled onions
getting big
a lot going on here on top of that goes
our finished big ass burger patty on top
of that goes our ham on top of that
goes a slice
of mozzarella cheese and a slice of
american cheese now it's not melted we
need to melt this so i'm going to hand
this off to my trusty assistant and she
is going to melt the cheese
yes
it's very hot put it down
is it that hot
oh [ __ ] that's hot
damn it oh yeah okay
ha ha hot
melty yummy that's [ __ ] hot
or crowning glory
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's so [ __ ] hot
now a pro tip a friend of mine in ohio
taught me was you squish it down and
then you flip it upside down because
right now the bottom of the bun is
completely destroyed so press it down
it's not really going anywhere
nice tip okay and then i'm gonna try to
get this thing in my face somehow by
going upside down [ __ ] it's hot [ __ ]
yeah oh it's hot hot plate
thank you for this this is a great
burger topic speed round number four the
last in the burger toppings round it's
not a topic it's not a burger it's a
drink i want a drink don't you want a
drink this is a weird one but stay with
me here okay this totally works the
witch doctor the witch doctor is a very
special drink for a very special place a
burger chain in north carolina called
whataburger not not that whataburger
from texas this is the north carolina
whataburger chain it's been on the menu
for over 60 years so it must be okay
right it is
it's fantastic recently i did a swing
through north carolina on a burger road
trip and i posted a picture of the witch
doctor and there were so many questions
so many questions i'm here to answer
those questions
number one what the [ __ ] is a witch
doctor so if you've ever gone around the
world with a self-serve soda fountain
which is when you take you know a little
bit from every soda in the fountain and
put in the same cup yoo-hoo then you
know what i'm talking about you've been
there before in this case we're going to
go around the world in a typical north
carolina soda fountain which would
include fun things like sun drop and
cherry lemon sundrop this has been
greeked out more greeks
pepsi
the blue can and dr pepper and most
importantly north carolina's very own
cheerwine all these things go in there
including you ready for this one a
little bit of pickle juice
dill pickles and lemon wedge
you ready
so first ice cubes in a cup okay a
little bit of beach right a little
splash of that going around the world
going around the world little squeeze of
lemon little splash of pickle juice and
then lots of pickles
[Music]
ah
i feel like a north carolina native
right now
that hit the spot
right there
sweet salty savory it's yum
ah it is really actually so refreshing
i'll see you next time burger scholar
sessions when i make you even hungrier
let's get hungry
[Music]
i think he's gonna blow
hey thanks for watching burger scholar
sessions you should like and subscribe
to this channel but also get more
episodes up here
somewhere in here right there
yeah watch more episodes right here